you came from a brawling background i
always thought you came from a wrestling
background but if you came from a
brawling background you know one of the
most impressive things is when a fighter
switches it and they go from being able
to inflict damage to being able to not
let someone inflict damage i mean one of
the things with floyd mayweather i think
is one of the most impressive things he
never gets credit for
this guy for 20 years had the best in
the world trying to hurt him and he just
wouldn't let them defense like he was
completely that's like the art of it
right so i mean when did you and your
career go from switching that mentality
from like dude i can hurt these dudes
too you know what these guys can't hurt
me i know exactly what to do to stop
them from from getting me um well i
started to use all my attributes you
know at one point you know you kind of
fall into the style because you're
coached by different people and you want
to do you know what they're telling you
to do but then you have to realize what
makes you unique and what made me me
unique was the fact that i was able to
move you know i was very shifty very
high energy very high energy so
i i utilize my movement more and then
when i could i'll utilize my grappling
and you know jam up the action so i
wasn't sitting there just you know
throwing punches with these big dudes
because at the end of the day you get
caught with one of those big shots and
you you you're not going to be standing
for too long you get caught by too many
because these four ounce gloves are a
very you know not much padding in them
at all and then underneath the four of
gloves it's like you have a cast on
because your your hands are wrapped so
it's a very uh very strong you just saw
that with steep and in ghana right like
i mean stipe is trying to control the
pace and and ghana's just waiting only
needs that one right hand and especially
with a guy like in ghana he got that an
accidental power where he just like he
just moves around and he just knocks him
now is that the baddest man on the
planet right now agano yeah i mean he he
is man and gano is something special
that's your number one baddest man on
the planet right now i would say so so
if you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast click
over here take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]